there's obviously one prime suspect
that's on people's minds i did actually
ask the foreign ministry spokesperson if
anyone was suspected in the attack and
he said to me it's too early to draw
conclusions but there is a long record
of russian assaults against ukraine and
yes we woke up this morning to find that
a number of of government websites uh
were temporarily down in fact the um the
website of the foreign ministry before
it went down was displaying um a warning
saying that all your information has
become public and be afraid and expect
worse
clearly now there's an investigation
underway the foreign ministry
spokesperson
that i mentioned said that specialists
are working on restoring the i.t systems
and the cyber police are investigating
what's happened but this attack comes at
a time of extreme tension over ukraine
you've had a week of diplomacy between
russia the united states nato allies and
wider european partners about security
in europe and principally security here
in ukraine with real concerns that there
is a risk of a new a further russian
physical invasion and you'll remember
that when russia annexed crimea back in
2014 and backed an insurgency in the
east of the country there were multiple
cyber attacks against critical
infrastructure in ukraine as well as
part of that assault and
russia has always been blamed for those
attacks and one of the things that
people have been looking for as an
indication of where this this tensions
this conflict could be going is
potentially new cyber attacks and so
while we haven't had confirmation as to
who caused the cyber attacks on the
websites today uh clearly it's a very
concerning sign at a time when tensions
are so high